education secretary miguel cardona is
facing calls to resign as a national
school board mem official claims he
solicited the letter
comparing protesting parents to domestic
terrorists you could tell the letter
came from the secretary of education
because all the spelling mistakes
thanks judge
if you remember uh the letter which the
board has since apologized for called
for federal action to address
hostilities towards school boards as
possible domestic terrorism and
suggested using the patriot act against
parents now that's patriotism arresting
a soccer mom for raising her voice at a
public meeting
now basically it's turned concerned
parents into isis and khakis
how long before they start waterboarding
the kids to get their parents netflix
passwords but that's politics these days
the government is cool with the taliban
tootling around on abandoned blackhawks
but they put mr and mrs johnson on a
watch list for asking why kids are
segregated by race the three r's have
gone from reading writing and arithmetic
to racism racism racism
even president biden's department of
justice relied on the letter in creating
its own memo directing the fbi to
investigate threats of violence in order
to combat combat a disturbing trend of
harassment of school officials
so we now live in a world where hardened
violent criminals are back on the street
five minutes after being arrested but
the fbi will kick your door down at dawn
with guns drawn if you leave a nasty
message on your kids science teachers
blackboard
i kid they don't teach science anymore
basically joe weaponized the doj to
silence people who were making a stink
these school boards tolerate speech like
their substitute teachers with a
hangover they want everybody to sit down
and shut up and no one learns a thing
of course since that letter things have
only gotten worse which could be the
motto under joe's official white house
portrait
witness the performance of him yesterday
emphasis on performance who in georgia
once again split america into two camps
you're either on his side or you're an
evil racist and that's the new stick
whose side do you want to be on
i ask every elected official in america
how do you want to be remembered at
consequential moments in history
they present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
do you want to be on the side of laverne
or shirley
ricky or lucy
how about hall or oats
curly or shemp
of course the bad guys and all these
comparisons that joe made are democrats
that joe actually once loved i mean it's
biden who repeatedly praised wallace in
the past even bragging about being
praised by him
i think biden was his babysitter but
like his phone number and how to get to
the oval office he's forgotten all of
that just as he's forgotten his praise
for former clan leader robert byrd
apparently the only white house the only
white sheets joe knows are the
waterproof ones on his bed
that's unfair
that's unfair judge i can't believe you
wrote that
so as usual the so-called uniter did
nothing but divide casting any critic of
his election changes as an attack on
democracy and in this effort to get rid
of the filibuster joe happily screamed
at america like the judge does when any
staffer makes eye contact with her i'm
tired of being quiet hear me plainly
the battle for the soul of america is
not over we have no option but to change
the senate rules including getting rid
of the filibuster for this pass the
freedom to vote act
pass it now i will defend the right to
vote our democracy against all enemies
foreign and yes domestic
yes
domestic meaning you
man i would say that didn't age well but
it's only been a day
joe biden is aging faster than a dozen
deviled eggs in the trunk of my car in
august
i mean listen to this
i did not walk in the shoes of
generations of students who walked these
grounds
but i walked other grounds because i'm
so damn old i was there as well they
think i'm kidding man
[Applause]
seems like yesterday the first time i
got arrested
oh do we know what the he's talking
about
no but that's only because he doesn't
know what he's talking about but once
again it's just him trying to use
falsehoods to divert from the truth this
guy came within a mile of a lie detector
it would catch on fire and explode which
seems to be a thing in his
administration here's top official jill
sanborn answering ted cruz's questions
about january 6th
sir i can't i can't answer that i can't
answer that sir sir i can't answer that
i'm aware of the individual sir uh
i don't have the specific background to
him sir i cannot answer that question
sir similar to the other answers i
cannot answer that not to my knowledge
sir
sounds like me when i get pulled over
without my pants on
it's amazing they hate the constitution
yet they plead the fifth more than a mob
rat on the witness stand so i think
we're learning what the presidency is
turning out to be it's a game of us
versus them and we are them in a bad way
and if you speak up about school policy
voting integrity or supporting the
police they'll tear through you like
brian stelter and a bag of funyuns
it would be something if joe tried to
reason with the people he disagrees with
but instead he does worse than write
them off he writes them up as white
supremacists bigots racist even
terrorists makes you long for the good
old days i mean way way back to oh i
don't know let's say 2019
you know when the president used to
defend rather than condemn americans hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else